benvenuti solo senato oggi giochiamo
gioco stranissimo che questi giochi più
popolari sullo slot e vogliamo anche
capire il perché perché dovremmo
scappare da una testa gigante e benefit
a testa girata è uno dei giochi più
sapevo la propria o se solo adesso mi
diceva che si sa la 10.000 persone che
stanno giocando quindi scopriremo
assieme perché a questo gioco è così
popolare perché piace così tanti vincerà
trombe vitale provate a indovinare di
publio fiori se tiri comodi prendete i
pop corn e lasciate un mi piace iniziamo
subito più mortali che questo sbrigativi
eccolo come
siamo che movimento molto
scappato perché
la pineta un
anno sono riuscito a scappare ma devo
riprovare di un labirinto bisogna
provare quindi l'uscita
tutto essere presi da l'acqua
che ha già preso due volte trova a
raggiungermi io sono una specie di muro
rosso così le teste non mi possono
prendere
dai team e così dietro mamma mia che sa
di sinistra su questo muro sono qui e
qui si corre di qua così qualcuno metta
una pezza tantissimi test
aiuto aiuto non tutti stasera cento
stiamo entra volta salta salta e sono
scappata
non ci può scappare nelle famiglie hanno
queste teste di quello che in vetta del
gioco
perché no anche con matti non capisco
perché questi muri sono trasparenti con
alcuni muri sono trasparenti forse per
farti capire dove dobbiamo andare quale
la società prezzo
ho trovato lo spreco zero testa gigante
castello
a papà è troppo strano a quanto pare non
scendere per quello che vi lasciate un
mi piace per non essere rincorsi da una
testa gigante e stanotte
che l'unica strada sia saltare sopra la
testa gigante di circolo rincorsa se una
frecciata contro l'avevamo sì si può non
era una trappola
no devo rifare tutto da capo
il problema è che io non mi ricordo le
strade
no io non mi ricordo resto lo stradone
videogiochi non ho stretto
dell'arredamento anche se mi chiedono le
indicazioni della città in cui ho
vissuto per reitani non lo so dai lidi
cassiani scrivete nei commenti se anche
per voi è così brava
tutto qua e morire così se si serviva a
milano quello sono io quello là sopra è
tutto dritto 29
aiuta
ci sei quasi tutto destra qui quindi la
frase volevo dire che bravo
per fortuna si può salvare qua almeno
dobbiamo ricominciare tutto daccapo
ovvero ma chi si sta ci sta la prima
cosa la bellezza si farà forte il capo
testa giganti che
si pone non era facile passarla ho
trovato un moneto redoro akiba
supermario states tu non ci credo sia
mio rimini spendendo stage2 gioco è
stranissimo vero divertente beh io seguo
vita allora qui sembra non ci siano test
secondo me ma punteranno fuori
all'improvviso
ecco dove non solo giovane di fatto
è una testa che brutte
ma lì non si passa neanche quindi si
contrae andare avanti e ci sono si deve
continuare andare avanti fine phone dove
ci sono varie fessure e poi vuoi salvare
alla fine del gioco scrivete un voto da
1 a 10 a questo gioco
è appreso non ci credo non mi freghi
testa ben fatta e ora fare attenti
perché ci sono dei ruoli che di valutare
la testa ma io no
non ci fosse non mi avrai vedetta
sbagliato doveva dare la palla parte
passiona troppo lo vivo di andare dritto
qua
non mi aspettavo che questo gioco
sarebbe stato così divertente ora
capisco perché popolare
stranissimo la
farina e
in seguito da dalle tette
non ci credo
aspettami è stato un ottimo state spesso
aspetta aspetta non sa stare al portiamo
prima nuovi stimoli perché un min di
vendetta
stimolo ferito buona quanto test caccia
di aver capito
dall'alto potere rarissimi per quello
che riesce allora io dai potenti amo
due teste una sopra l'altra si fa sempre
più difficile
le tappe diventano sempre più grandi per
fate pagina sia successo
siamo il ri contro di qua pregate
possiamo salvare quattro dai questa era
abbastanza semplice aspetta deve ancora
vedere le doppie test è
passati dall angolo privati vi sono un
sacco di dischi come dobbiamo un attento
perché se cari sul disco giri come
quella testa vedi aspetta un attimo e
cerchiamo di capire dove dobbiamo andare
forzata questa parte non è la strana
sono di qualità di qua seguì l'ho
trovata
attento c'è la testa come fosse il segno
di qua mi vedi viene solo fatto ancora e
allora qui ok poi passare a testa non a
far muovere fi salva
wow siamo fortissimi di qua
attento
hanno preso vita le poverine e capillare
dai sbrigati v ora quanti cerchi qua
non si capisce
tutto e di laurea subito ecco vitale
40 accorta che c'era già una testa qua
brigati
se il capo detto
e poi se ne dite ma chi
inventa storie
è stato preso dalla terry di teste
poverino ecco vitale da in cui porto o
meno male la testa di caruso cascato
buon povero evitare lo giudico tale
noi parliamo dobbiamo scegliere una
porta ecco questa è una testa lia
nostro giocatore qui
sono caduto nel fallimento di lava con
le ghette ovviamente cerchiamo di capire
dove di restare qua si
no sono tantissime ma forse questa è la
sfida finale nuova stavo prendendo la
porta sbagliata aiuto è possibile
stampare da tutte queste tre
mesi
vediamo cosa ci dobbiamo arrivare laggiù
dove c'è la scala che ti amo come si può
fare
ok io gli ho seguite
per mettere dentro i lego si no va bene
sono tantissime come si fa a fattore
i barbari che la forza né da lì dobbiamo
prendere un'altra strada
puoi camminare sulla loro testa prova
sopra se
non ci credo sì c'è così tanto in testa
posso passare perché non abbiamo
scoperto un prodotto la volta del
velocissimo loro coraggioso eroe
dove dobbiamo andare ora possiamo vedere
qui se non ci perdiamo ma questo attento
questo labirinto a specchi non si
capisce è vero ma è chiuso ma mai troppo
la si fosse una strada giusta quella che
hai preso
siamo riusciti a superare anche qui
tutto chiaro wow ecco una testa gigante
cos'è quella cosa di una pallina rossa
un amore
era una trappola troppo
[Musica]
questo è il livello finale
tascabili non ci credo mi sono salvato
simile alla calre o no anche l'altro è
caduto anche l'altro sui rom
ok ce l'ho fatta dai salta poi
siamo al buio quando abbiamo la pila
vero
testa dove andiamo c'è una porta qua che
è pronto a vedere le teste al buio dove
sei vieni semplice sono dietro
ok ora io seguo te a me trovato
morto vitale rimasto incastrato in un
abito se volete la seta
brava subito a sinistra bravissima ci
siamo qui non è questo questa questa
quanto finora
ok piano adesso è perché complesso no
non è qui non
era quella dopo non era questa adesso
non la prima ma la seconda va
purtroppo abbiamo perso vitale si per
ribaltoni e ma che strano questo stage
vaio
che firma
volta di supermario fighissimo no è
troppo bello
bellissimo
wow un solo
no è bellissimo questo gioco non me lo
sarei mai aspettata tempo che anche qui
c'era un'altra più gravissima
esplosa come sempre partono prima i
capelli
la tetta mai fatto si
aspetta adesso cerca di capire dove si
deve andare
è troppo divertente ma con
wow ma sei stata bravissima qui non si
crea poche piano piano ok ora a saltare
qua
devi cercando di amare un posto per
salvare
ma cioè sei stata veramente troppo bravo
anche mister allenate punto per mario
wow stiamo arrivando al boss finale
delle teste pezzo per acqua ma perché ei
per il trasporto leggo no no aspetta ci
sono le bollicine vai e orale testi che
fanno anche gli effetti speciali
sembrano tipo dei cristalli di ghiaccio
brava salva non avevo vista quello testa
devo saltare così si fa no vabbè
bravissima corri corri con sé anche
brutte queste zeppe un po complesso
penso qui è
noto gli di
lavoro
corri
bravissima wow e queste e superati tutti
guarda c'è la testa con le donne che il
colore si è fatto a che ora
mamma mia che brutta
lavaggi sui consigli ma io voglio
tornare come ero prima
wow attenta delle teste sono palle di
neve assieme alle terze ovviamente non
possono mancare
è una cosa folle
quello che veramente
assurda beh ci sei quasi zero fatta
o no adesso c'è la discesa anche
i cubetti di ghiaccio
andiamo proviamo a passare qua no sì no
no no brava brava brava pechino continua
motivo
che brutte quella tempo si fa scivolare
ok dai ci manca pochissimo
ci facevo l'acqua una va beh credo che
ce l'avrà
e dove siamo su marte il pavimento è
nata a toccarlo cosa ovviamente non
mancano mai le teste ma è troppo
divertente questo gioco sembra di
giocare una sorta di super mario ma un
super mario
vai vai wow non ci credo che non mi
servirà per l'ondata di
salviamo ci sono i muri adesso attenta a
non rimanere spiaccicato in mezzo a due
muri
c'è anche una fiat
brava
troppo divertente fatto volete che la
pianti diamo mai state un bel mi piace
se questo video avete già 10 mia mi pare
però non vuoi consiglio dal gioco delle
teste che tronco di loritello ora villa
savo 4 casilino di cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite buona visione ciao